well bees back to share they'd never  seen speed like this before lovely store  calling I was dubbed the fastest man in  Ravi heard a boat heard of Phelps but  you haven't heard of me yet I'm the  fastest man don't limp us when I get the  ball burn anyone in my path who does  that better than him I'm in the 44.1  three seconds fastest NFL history  everybody wants to see I run I got  killer speed leaving opponents in my way  no location there's just no way you can  contain him leading the score at the  school at the school when I'm not doing  that  tear it up at the truth we ran a hundred  meters to the ten point nine three  seconds that's it  I'm calling I'll watch me win gold if  you could see me